Willie come to me come to me in my time
of need
hold me good morning Hank it's Sunday
some snowy day in December and today I
am going to conquer one of my greatest
phobias Heights
should I Willie tell this story instead
of me telling it maybe so it'll be
easier to cope
ok so John recently went to an author
party with Scott Westerfeld and Justine
Marvell SDA and they were teasing him
about his profound fear of heights and
they pointed to a table in a hotel room
and said how much would it cost for you
to stand on top of that table so John
had to come up with a monetary figure
that was high enough that he wouldn't
have to stand on the table but low
enough that he wouldn't seem entirely
crazy for being unwilling to stand on
top of the table dude his profound fear
of heights and the number he finally
came up with five thousand dollars to
which scott westerfeld's and justine
Orville SDA said okay and then offered
to make a donation of five thousand but
Willie you are supposed to be telling
this story not licking and then offered
him a donation of five thousand dollars
to his favorite charities if he would
stand on top of the table and then being
my courageous owner I'm sure you can
imagine what John did next
he completely failed to get on top of
the table because he is a gigantic wuss
but Scott and Justine agreed to extend
the deadline of table standing until
today so today I am going to stand on
top of a table for the children I mean
people are gonna think that I'm
literally crazy
can we take my pulse for the purposes of
showing that I'm legitimately afraid
what do you think it is I'm not I I
don't think getting on the table will be
hard at all I think that standing on the
table will be exceptional so I guess I
just yeah yeah I can't do it i litter I
don't think I can do it man
get on the table
I'm going to do it I'm going to do it
and then I'm going to and then I'm going
to stand up on the table
and then I'm going to get right back
down okay coming up in the countdown I'm
in it I'm going to stand up on the table
I'm going to get right back down I'm
gonna go right now I'm gonna go I'm off
okay come on the table
ha ha ha ha ha yeah I got on the table I
stood on the table yes $5,000 hey I
don't want to brag but I think that
today I have shown a lot of you know
physical courage I have proven once and
for all that nerdfighters are tough
it's like Franklin Delano Roosevelt said
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
and Heights I'll see you tomorrow
willy-nilly let's run through this all
together